[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone I'm here with the co-chairs
of the Microsoft research faculty summit
Dan Fey and Donnell cosmic gentlemen
what are the goals of the Microsoft
Research faculty summit so actually the
goals this year are in overall have
always been how do we bring together not
only our researchers but external
researchers and even our product
engineers and thinkers together to
actually have some dialogue and
scholarly discourse and exchange of
ideas and like in this case this year
we're focusing on systems because we
really think that it's a key aspect
that's needing to have more dialogue as
we're going forward so Donald why focus
on systems yes so systems are very
important we are seeing huge changes in
the world today and most of these
changes are actually fueled by
innovations on systems so systems are
integrated they become invisible
computation becomes invisible in our
everyday life and that is systems
innovations well when you think about
innovation you also think about
challenges what are some of the big
challenges for systems researchers say
in the next 10 years so our grand vision
is that the whole world become will
become one big machine one computer and
one of the biggest challenges how do we
program this computer how do we reason
about security of this computer and how
does this computer interact with people
because ultimately we want to help
people so what does success look like
helping people drive more innovation and
research part of it is get the open
dialogue going between us external folks
and also to have a lot of the
researchers focus on those long-term
challenges that we see happening so we
all can have a success in this and you
know yes I'll be papers all the other
things and collaborations but it's
really about the success of the industry
so what future disruptions might systems
research fuel so we are seeing almost in
every domains
an infusion of computation so one of the
areas as agriculture we we expect like
massive improvements and sustainability
reduction in water usage reduction in
chemicals just by infusing computation
into the everyday processes that farmers
have and that happen in farms well
gentlemen this is a great event thank
you so much
[Music]
[Applause]